what up Internet I just seen here and
this is vlog University this is the
shell that I have created teach you guys
how to vlog and give you inspiration on
what to vlog about my number one
question that I always get from you guys
is what do i vlog and how do i vlog well
let me show you guys my setup because
that's another big question that you
guys are constantly asking me Justine
what's your setup like what do you do
are you in a studio no I'm just in a
small little room but I kind of turned
you my office slash studio and most
importantly I've got this white wall
behind me here I have some fantastic
lights I'm pretty sure I just bought
these at Target and you'll also notice
that I'm wearing some fantastic tie-dye
pants that you guys can't even see I've
got I laptop here with all of my
questions and all of your video
responses that you guys send me and for
audio I use a Sennheiser wireless
microphone and the microphones right
there and the microphone is wirelessly
hooked up to a Canon Vixia FS 11
camcorder and for those of you that are
wondering what camera I use when I'm out
vlogging I used this canon powershot SD
960 it takes still photos and it takes
really good video most of my first music
videos yep
shot with this little guy
and I love this camera so much that I'm
gonna give one away to you guys and no
this is not a sponsored video I just
absolutely love this camera and it's
perfect for vlogging and I want you guys
to be able to vlog as well for all the
details on what you need to do to get
this camera just check out my blog at
iJustine dot-com and it will explain it
all to you and now let's get to vlog
University in the last episode of log
University your homework assignment is
to create a video take away the audio
and add your own commentary now you guys
sent me some great videos but here's a
few that made the cut into this episode
number one and number two the majestic
creature the honey bee oh look at the
honeybee running away with Elizabeth
Shue oh my gosh look at elizabeth madly
running a honeybee oh I'm nervous
um my name is mr. snuggles I'm three
weeks old
number five sit here and let this kid
touch me and pretend like it doesn't
bother me I should fight him yeah
that'll teach him well congrats to
everyone who made it into this episode
and if he didn't happen to be one of
those few don't worry you can try again
next week for that homework assignment I
want you guys to go out and film
yourself with an imaginary pet no I
don't care if you actually have a real
pet because that's not what we want here
we want imaginary pets go out and play
fetch with your imaginary dog talk to
your imaginary parent brush your
imaginary lizard's hair what are you
doing you're so weird
once you're done shooting it editing
your video just upload it to this video
here as a video response and that's it
don't forget to subscribe so you know
when I launch a new video here on my
iJustine channel and check out the rest
of my youtube channels here and last but
not least check out my website did I
just seem calm see how you can get
yourself a camera bye